okay
fingers crossed on this is this working
am i coming through
please tell me this is working
ah i'll find out in a minute
there is a delay by doing it this way
which
it's going to take me a little bit to
get used to
but uh i think it's working
waiting for somebody to confirm
can you see me can you hear me
you can hear me see me ah
this is like my first time messing
around with my
setup i'm using a webcam i'm
actually using like streaming software
so that i have better
theoretically i have better control over
what i'm doing
this is a whole new deal and uh
i i don't know how foolish it was i'm
gonna pull this in a little tighter i
don't know how foolish it was
for me to debut this on uh
on something where i'm like
doing something unusual like trying to
raise money
uh so oh boy
so um hi everybody who's currently
here um trying to
uh think of where we start
um on this thing uh hang on a second
checking something
all right cool so um off to
my is this thing gonna how's this thing
gonna show my hands so it should be nope
that side should be that side you will
see a pie chart
and that represents the funds i'm trying
to raise
to cover a tax bill
so uh the actual annoying thing
is that this is not even the tax bill
from this past year this isn't the tax
bill
for my first year of having this be my
job
this is an this is to pay for an
error that happened on
taxes done like a couple of years ago
and it was a mistake
but it doesn't matter why if it was a
mistake i still have to pay
for it um the the annoying thing is it
got caught in an audit and i
i i would bet money that the reason they
audited me
is because i'm now self-employed uh
so
uh okay jack i see your question it's
not an
uninteresting one but i'm i would really
like to not do politics
um tonight i really
really wouldn't so um so i've got this
tax bill
that i have to pay well i that
you know and i'm really hoping i think
i've gotten things sorted where my taxes
um for 2020 shouldn't be too bad
so hopefully i'm not here doing this
again uh and you know after
uh after april 15th but
um here's here's what we're looking at
i am trying to raise money and
the first thing i want you to notice i
if you look in the description
on this you will see that
um
that i put the link for my paypal
in there because if you are going
to contribute to this that would be my
preferred way that you
do it because
anything brought in through super chats
while appreciated i'm not going to tell
you not to do it but anything
sent that way youtube does take a cut of
things sent to the paypal that is not
going to be an
issue so uh that would be my preferred
method if you either don't use paypal or
you're not comfortable doing it or you
would just rather hit me up with a super
chat that is all
fine again don't let me discourage you
from doing so uh just realize that
that is the preferred thing uh what's
the goal
okay so the the goal that i sent is that
is set is not actually the total amount
of the tax bill
and i also don't expect to hit it
but the goal is
the goal is two thousand dollars um
which i don't expect to hit but i set it
at
less than the actual total amount of the
tax bill because i
figured if i set that as the goal i'd be
even more depressed when i didn't
when i came way way way way way short of
that
so uh again uh you will see the
pie chart that and you'll see some of it
is already orange because i had already
got
some donations in through paypal now
there's a couple of other things
while there will be portions of this
where i will kind of break
from doing other stuff and engage
in things like a q a i'm going to do
something for the purposes of this live
stream
that i don't normally do and is not
going to become the norm
i'm not going to make this a standard
thing
however for this one stream i
am gonna put a hard line on not
answering questions that don't either
come in the form of super chats
are attached to a paintball payment or
are sent over the discord
uh because the discord is exclusive to
patreon and people supporting me
i like i this whole thing
is going to be really awkward
for me because i'm not comfortable
asking for money i'm really really not
and i'm not comfortable
paywalling stuff but
this time i i
in the interest of having this actually
generate anything
i am gonna basically paywall access
to me and in terms of answering your
questions and things like that
i will be checking the paypal
periodically to see if new payments have
come
in and whether or not those came with
any questions that need answering
so you'll see me pick up the phone from
time to time and
there's already some there so i need to
record those for the pie chart and see
if there are
questions attached to them that's
something that i will do intermittently
as we go along give me a second here and
let me get
this updated wow okay
that whoo
that that was that was more right off
the bat than um
than i was expecting all right let me
get this covered here we got
that and
[Music]
that and
i am not going to um say out loud but
any of these dollar amounts are or who
sent them
unless somebody requests a shout out
which you can
certainly do um but i don't i don't ever
want to presume that people are okay
with or comfortable with that so
you'll notice some more of the pie chart
has now filled out
nice right um so that's
that's where things are going and we
i've got a number of things planned
because
right now i'm planning on three hours
this will end
either um when i hit the three hour mark
or it will end um
when i hit the goal which again uh i
don't
i don't actually expect to be able to do
um
so there is going to be stuff going on
uh stuff that will hopefully amuse you
and uh including some stuff that yes i
will be taking your feedback on even
without
super chats but like that's that's
specifically for questions and we can
start
this little telethon with
doctor who mad libs uh let me just say
this you know what's really weird for me
is that there is way more
of a delay between when i say something
when it goes out
with this setup i'm using than i am used
to
so that there are probably going to be
awkward moments in this as a result of
that
i'm sorry in advance and it seems oddly
more
um i don't know
it does it feels slightly more
distancing with the delay because the
the feedback
is um it's just slower
uh okay so what we're gonna do we're
gonna start with some ad-libs
and so i'm going to ask the chat and i
will not necessarily
necessarily oh boy this is off to a good
start i will not necessarily be taking
the first suggestion that goes out for
each of the things that i will
ask for i am going to take um
probably the first one that i find to be
amusing or
interesting or i think will be
entertaining so
oh for god's sake and now i'm dropping
the pencil
i haven't started drinking yet i promise
you
anyway if i could get
from the chat an adjective
and i'm gonna have to think of stuff to
say while i'm waiting for
words due to this dang delay
from the uh from my saying it to the
chat and it's oh god it's like 30
seconds
that's
oh boy and like i get it now
i've seen way i've seen so many other
people stream and it seemed like oh boy
they don't respond to stuff very quickly
like oh
this is why they were way more
sophisticated in their setup and the
fallback of that is uh
um you know that the there's this delay
oh here we go um i'm go
oh i'm going with naughty
i need a plural noun
and then after that a place you know
what i'm gonna do these in chunks of two
so i need a plural noun and a place
i i'm seeing encouragements for me to
get drunk like look
i have water that will be made
um uh that
available to me and that'll be tapped
into later but there's a long haul i'm
not dipping into it yet
uh let's see
kind of uh colored pencils i like that
and let's see
my house taking that as the place
uh can i get another plural noun and
then a
void why am i slipping into this voice i
don't know
what are you gonna do about it nothing
69 viewers
nice
what do you mean that's not water
it says water goodness
people are so untrusting these days
[Music]
let's see
i i see you people having fun at my
expense
which i enjoy for the record i am i'm
the self-deprecating type
uh ooh
fingers
um and ooh
slap that's a good verb uh
all right let's
um this one says person in the room
you know what we get the person in the
chat let's go with that
um so a person in the chat
and then an adjective
i'm just watching these other uh options
go by this is already entertaining
if the doctor lies then the flask can
too oh
oh dear uh
okay i i do also have to stay properly
hydrated as well
me that's the obvious choice
asmr quotes it's because i'm using my
good mic
which like that's a first
all right gotta go with
that one um and adjectives take
that
all right i need another adjective and a
noun
oh and while you folks are doing that
i'm gonna
just take a peek okay
boy
[Laughter]
oh that was sweet okay
cool so i gotta update that
so what is okay uh
like that one
and now now now now now
taking that and let me update
this
more orange we like more orange
um i need a verb and a plural noun
see oh i've got
i've got part of um
[Music]
i've got i've got part of a [ __ ]
stuck in my head because i i had thrown
to get the latest tick tock that i threw
together uses a
section out of that so i just got the
the beat with that um
i've just got that in my head on loop
right now oh hey meg
it's nice to see you um
oh okay uh here we go verb oh i like
that
um so i've got my verb
plural noun
taking that one
i need a verb ending with ing and then a
different
person in the chat from uh
well i can't i didn't say who i picked
so i can't say from just
i'll just take suggestions for a person
i suppose i could
um i could just pick that myself
all things considered
well-armed peasants i've heard that one
gozer that that was that was a that was
a cute
parody
uh let's see oh i'm echoing
ah dang it hang on
give me a second uh
thank you very much laylee
that was a very cute sticker
um
all right so hold on i'm going to take a
break from
that am i still echoing
is that still going okay let me see if i
can sort that
i suppose i need to keep talking if i'm
gonna try and
get this dealt with
all right so hold on i'm going to take a
break from
that am i still echoing oh yeah i can
hear it
okay is that still going okay let me see
if i can sort that
it's not awful
hold on
that might have been part of it i'm not
sure though
uh
all right am i am i still echoing i
think i've got it sorted
um
can you can i sing with myself on delay
if i
sing i risk the thing being demonetized
and that that
will go very badly
uh yeah i'm silicon
no okay hang on let me try something
else
um can i change that
all right hold on if i switch
right if i switch to that which i don't
love
um let's see if that's still echoing and
i have to wait for the
delay to quit to hear if that
has sorted things
ah
no that's worse
for crying out loud
okay so that's not good
oh i knew i knew that i was going to
have tech problems on this one
and i knew it was going to be something
that i didn't know how to sort
wait a minute oh
um hello
now okay that's what's supposed to be
there
wait is it gone
okay now it's gone i don't even know
what i did
but okay great
oh all right this is uh
this is going so smoothly all right
where did we leave off we left off
folks i need a noun and then a plural
noun
different nouns ideally
ah okay
while i'm waiting on that quick pop over
here
oh and this uh while i'm waiting for
nouns this one came with a question
have you heard the album transgender
dysphoria blues by against me
um i have i've heard some of it
um i i really need to take the time and
like dedicated
uh listen to it which i haven't had the
time to like do properly
i've been meaning to for a while ooh i
like that one um
and
that one we're almost done um
i need a verb ending in ing
and an adjective
famous tech solution i don't even know
what i did 100 accurate yeah yeah it is
ah thank you comp girl thanks for being
you oh
thank you oh i need to update the pie
chart
now uh and
so let's see
this is um this is a solid start
i'm i'm kind of impressed um
that we got that much going already
okay coming on back um
i like that
and
uh all right last thing i need
i need an exclamation
drinking later my friend later
did i bring in oh good yes i did
this this is for later
mmm pie chart i know right
uh my favorite um homer simpson
um was always the one where like
he's yelling at this he's yelling like
he's yelling at god
and he's like why do you mock me oh lord
marge comes in
hunger that's not god it's just a waffle
that bart threw up there she knocks this
waffle off the ceiling and homer catches
it
i know i shouldn't eat thee but
[Music]
sacrilicious
something about sacrilicious i'm quite
fond of
ooh that's a lot of exclamations um
let's see i'm good oh there we go
okay my friends mad lib
story time exterminate
the doctor's greatest enemies are the
daleks
a naughty race of mutated colored
pencils
from the planet my place these fingers
have spread across the universe
in search of worlds to slap
created by the sinister just carowind
these sparkly beings are encased in a
shell
of playful armor that resembles a
metallic floozy
the daleks prance across time and shafts
bent on thrusting the universe ms wicked
wolf almost defeated the daleks once
and for all during the last great
waffle war both the daleks and the time
tentacles
were seemingly wiped out however some
daleks escaped this fate
can still be found fiddling the universe
with their sticky battle cry
smeg
i have fun with those it's been a long
time since i've uh
since i've done one of those but they
are uh they are they are quite enjoyable
um let's see hold on i've got my list of
things to do uh
oh huh since people
enjoy seeing me suffer
i should oh i'm gonna need
a boy hang on i gotta think here for a
second
uh i'm gonna have to make two all right
so there will be more mad libs but i'm
gonna i'm gonna take a break from that
um
just because like with the delay uh they
they are a little bit cumbersome
uh to set up but um
there there will be some more of those
mad libs from the 70s oh god
i didn't even realize they were around
that long so
people may recall that in times past
i had um i used to
randomly pick beans out of
bertie bott's every flavored bean
i see what i ended up with well
obviously i'm not going to do that for
reasons of branding and not
wishing to lend even the possible
perception of support for a certain
franchise and its creator
what i do have instead is i have
been boozled which in many ways
is more sinister than bertie bott's
every flavored beans and here is why
would you ever with the every flavored
beans if you could
match the design on the bean to
the the guide on the box
you knew what you were going to get
however with bean boozled
every given design has two options
like for example there's one that could
be juicy pear
or it could be booger it could be
coconut
or it could be baby wipes so you don't
know what you're gonna get
and so for your amusement there will be
some of this oh thank you very much
connor let me add let let's
let's get that pie a little bigger
and come back
contra points put out a new video today
about jk rowling i did see it
actually it's over 90 minutes long i
think it's one of the best videos she's
ever produced
it's very good it's very very thorough
i mean contra points i'm i know there
are some con
and there have been some controversial
issues around her but i think
her work is incredibly well done
obviously she has production values
beyond
anything i could probably ever hope to
attain but
that was a really well constructed and
well put together
video i did see that one so
i'm gonna grab a bean all right this is
either going to be
oh see i'm gonna have to do another one
right after this because even worst case
scenario
this one will not be that bad so this is
either going to be
berry blue or toothpaste
so let's find out
as toothpaste i just got the mint on it
it is kind of impressive that it's not
just a generic mint flavor
it does taste very specifically like
toothpaste
i don't know how the heck they do this
to be honest
there should be hamilton mad libs there
probably are i just don't have them
hold on i i was seeing what i was
getting and i'm trying not to i'm trying
to go blind
ah okay what is this this is
oh god see now this one
this one is cruel
because it's either peach which is one
of my favorite jelly bean flavors
because i like
citrusy candy
or barf
barf is one of the worst ones to get
because it takes a second to hit you
just simping real quick brian i
encourage simping
um but let me add that to the chart
i i even put something together in excel
for this
like i'm pulling all the
all the skills so
here we go and even if this is peach
it's gonna taste weird cause i still got
the mint on my
tongue but
i think it's peach oh no
oh no it's not
oh god see that's what i'm talking about
oh that's what i mean because it starts
out that kind of
slightly sickly sweet that you don't
know if it's gonna get better or if it's
just gonna like
come in behind you just yeah and then it
it lingers on your tongue
i hate that one okay
thank you very much rusty
uh 13 39 13 and 39
are my lucky numbers
i don't have any requests that aren't
that aren't and nsfw but i do hope this
telephone goes well
thank you very like here's the annoying
thing
um if you knew me in real in real life
i'm like i ain't above uh an nsfw
request but you know youtube
uh and i've yet to launch and only fans
haven't gone that far yet
and eva serration thank you so much
hello from the other side of the pond do
you intend to watch russell t
davies's new series it's a sin it's
caused quite a stir in the lgbt
community over here right now i've got a
lot of people asking me about that one
um
and i i would like to see it it's not
yet available stateside
it's going to be on hbo max but they
don't have a date yet it's just
early 2021 they don't have a release
date for it yet so i think the same
thing happened with
years and years which i also still
haven't seen
where it came out not that long after
its debut in the uk but
it um but it did there was a delay and i
think that's that's what we're dealing
with here
so thank you very much and let me get
these amounts added to the total
cool that is looking pretty
i love it
uh
by the way brach means barf or vomit in
yiddish pro tip
i i probably mispronouncing that anyway
all right
so
[Applause]
i'll do one more of these then i'm going
to break from these
sons of okay so what's that that is
this is either oh
see that this one's not going to be
pleasant either way
this is either tutti frutti which is a
flavor i don't really care for
or it's stinky socks
and so help me if this turns out to be
stinky socks i'm gonna start to believe
that this is rigged
because like that'll be three in a row
where it was the bad option
but uh okay
set it perfectly ah sweet
all right
oh god oh
i was dumb and didn't get a spit cop so
i have nowhere to yeah
oh son of a pitch
oh my god
oh yeah i am um
i'm putting those over there
oh i don't know what was worse that that
or the
the bra because um
oh like that that just hit you
right off the bat
so i take it it's tutti frutti
[Laughter]
thank you cara can't donate much but
wanted to support
i hope you have a good couple of hours
thank you so much and like seriously any
amount
is a help it is going to help me
get on to the other side of this
nonsense
need a splatoon yeah i kind of i kind of
do
all right let me get that
okay um and like as far as
kind of how i i like said i was uh i was
drawing a line
on the answering questions and less not
answering questions unless they're super
chats like that's in any amount if you
just want to chuck a buck at me to ask a
question
that that works like don't don't think
i'm like
you you must you must pay a minimum
amount to receive any of my attention
now
you know what let's
let our hair down a little bit
thank you very much camp girl you
deserve extra for that
hey whatever will net me some extra
whatever um i will happily take it
i'm sorry comp girl i might have said
camp girl that's what if that's what i
said i apologize
but thank you thank you very much
add that to the total
that is looking nice very nice
um okay trying to think of what
i want to do next i think where are we
for time
all right so um
i'm thinking at one of the things that i
was planning to do
is get super self-indulgent
probably to my uh to my error
i am actually going to read a short
story of mine
um i figure i will do that at eight
um that just feels like a good time to
strap in for that because it that'll
take up a bit of time
uh and obviously once i'm done with that
i'll have to catch up on donations and
super chats and
everything else thank you connor i
haven't sketched anything in over two
years but today i did a sketch for a
friend
on some paper uh of me wrapping her in a
warm hug she loved it oh
that sounds wonderful and that's great
that you're drawing again
like when you've been off something for
a long time it
it can be really tough getting back in
that habit
like if that's just even if it's a
one-off
that's that's fantastic
uh council of geeks needs an
intervention um for
masochistic sweets addiction uh
yeah i i i think i need an intervention
for the things i'm willing to do for
attention
i think that might be the truth of it
thank you renee
and meg thank you very much what's your
favorite cocktail and no
hard cider is not an acceptable answer
okay yeah fine
like i i don't know if i have a favorite
though i have
i have a collection of go-to's
i'm quite fond of a paloma which uh
is primarily grapefruit juice and
tequila
they balance each other really really
well a good
safe default if you don't know if the
bartender's any good
is just vodka and cranberry um
although every now and then like a white
russian that's that's a nice one as well
but i'm also the kind of person who will
browse the um
the custom cocktails at a bar and see if
any of those catch my eye
um thank you very much simone what's
good fam big love from
birmingham well thank you so much all
right i got amounts i need
to add in here so hang on give me a
second
make sure i'm doing this correctly
maybe we'll see all right so i did that
i got that one okay
two
that and that one
trying to make sure i keep track of
everything
okay so get back here
oh you know what's something that just
occurred to me
i had been checking my paypal on my
phone
given how many of my um
uh viewer bases in the uk
or europe i should probably like log
into
paypal proper because when you get
um money in a foreign currency sometimes
you have to approve it before it shows
up
so let me um check that real quick
oh okay and yes there is yeah
there is some of that indeed so
okay so let me catch up on this let me
accept
that had uh
i had some australian dollars i had to
accept
at least i think that's what that was um
get back to where i was you focusing
just
you get to listen to me talk to myself
as i fiddle my way through
uh through paypal
all right some of these came with
questions
and so i am going to tackle those
let's see now i just want i just need to
hear you say
oh oh
this is cruel okay fine somebody's gonna
clip this
i know they are now i just need to hear
now i just need you to say
after much consideration i now feel that
clara
is the best companion in the history of
doctor who
sorry i don't know what that was
[Laughter]
so let me get these amounts
added in and we'll see where we stand
there are probably there's probably
something i could have done to like keep
track of this stuff for me
but i ain't that savvy so
get that
cool looking nice
and popping on back to where i can
actually
see you folks again alrighty
uh cool
ah so where what
i now now have lost track of like where
where i was and what i was doing
okay cool did that awesome
uh you know what i think
let's have a one more go at a mad lib
and then i sh then i shall
tell you a story and i expect by the
time i'm done
everyone will have bailed but
you know i couldn't get anyone to pick
it up for publication so
figure somebody will listen
all right and oh boy this is this is
going to go badly right off the bat
i need an adjective
and a part of the body
uh asking this group for part of the
body
that this this
this is a mistake
ah
let's see
sorry this uh carolyn there's somebody's
dropping some yeah thank you you got him
thank you very much
uh let's go with that one
we're gonna go with squishy
and that little dangly thing that swings
in the back of my throat
[Laughter]
um all right i need a noun
and an adverb
of my body the lobe in my brain that
contains the memory of hellbent
i ain't writing that down funny as it is
um
adjective raunchy well that's just
describing me
see oh table um
maybe see what else we oh we're go oh
we're going animals
um
let's oh
we're gonna go with pig and
uh
um see the problem is like there's a
bunch of these i could go with but like
they
they fit it too well to the point of
being boring
quickly slowly cautiously swiftly
um you know what i'm going to inject one
lagubriously
i need a plural noun and then a singular
noun
like when i when i have more than one
noun i could make my life easier by
um pulling from the pool of nouns
already suggested but
that's that's no fun
oh goodness
i'm sorry carolyn i have a feeling that
uh
that person's gonna keep popping back
gazongas i'll take that
and
uh
i'm gonna take pumpkin
i need oh i need another plural noun and
another noun so you know what this time
i am just gonna pull from
the ones i've got we're gonna go with uh
babies
and
uh
bourbon
uh i need another noun and an adverb
oh my god
so uh i'm i'm looking for a noun and an
adverb
die
[Music]
backstreet boy i like that
and
hilariously
like that
i'm oh boy i need an article of clothing
and a verb ending in i
n g
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh
so i like it it doesn't make for great
television me just
reading the chat and chuckling but like
it's it's
we're going with thongs that was super
insistent
that's uh we're taking that one
and for verb ending in ing
um
[Music]
um i need an adjective and a
and two silly words
that's all it says silly words an
adjective and two silly words
[Music]
i'm waiting for that
okay
uh ooh fluffy
i like fluffy
secretly a cat no actually i'm secretly
a pigeon
numpty
and let's see that's another silly word
here
i've already got gazongas i'm not using
them again
uh
rubbers
um
whack-a-doo i could do i like why i
could do
okay here we go this one
my friends
tiny why me
the doctor leaned against the console
with a squishy look in his uvula
that's the thing about pig travel he
said while
lugubriously pressing a few buttons and
pulling a few gazongas
the pumpkin continued to spiral across
all of space and time
most babies think time is a strict
progression of bourbon to effect
one uh one backstreet boy
leads hilariously to another he adjusts
his thongs
as he always did when he was meowing but
actually from a non-linear
non-subjective viewpoint he added
it's more like a fluffy ball of wibbly
wackadoo
timey numpty stuff
[Laughter]
pressing a few buttons pulling a few
gazongas that was
oh dear you people do not disappoint me
[Laughter]
uh all right so where are we
all right i'm gonna check the
paypal
and
then i shall read to you
now the thing is it had actually been my
original
intention to
um
oh my goodness wow okay that was a
let me get that at it it had been my
uh we're almost a quarter of the way
again i actually don't expect to hit
this goal i'll be shocked if i do
um but it was my original intention to
have
several options um for
short things that i've i've written to
read to you
uh the problem was when i was looking
them over and like realizing oh god
you know sort of they need needed clean
up because i hadn't looked at them in
years
and i had time to fix one
so you you won't have the options
i was going to prep a sci-fi story
and um a horror story
the horror story is uh is not ready for
prime time
so you folks will be getting a sci-fi
story
which i suppose is a little bit more
fitting given
the consistency of doctor who
in my content not that this is
fanfic or anything like that this is
original
work this is a short story that i wrote
oh god ages ago now um
initially but um
i'm actually still even though it needed
cleanup
i am um i'm still
i'm still quite proud of this
so here we go let me
get in a position where this is going to
be comfortable all right
so i shall read to you now
mel
in the darkness of the sleeping quarters
a few lights blinked idly along the wall
the room vibrated ever so slightly from
the humming engines
the only sound cutting through the white
noise was the occasional snore from one
of the grey flannel sheets draped atop
the bunk embedded in the wall
outside the porthole window the darkness
was more all-encompassing despite the
scattered pinpricks of light
each too far away to be more than a
reminder of how remote the vessel was
the digital clock ticked by another
minute and a sound almost like a sigh of
exasperation came over the pa system
the lights in the room flashed on the
lump under the sheets groaned and
shifted before
going still once more
after a pause the lights in the room
became brighter
and easily penetrated the linens oh
come on baby just give me five minutes
the voice from the sheets was weary
and gravelly in contrast the voice that
filled the room in response was
pleasants
and kindly though with a note of
irritation
i gave you another five minutes 20
minutes ago
you need to get up frank with an exasper
with an exaggerated huff the sheets were
thrown back clumsily fluttering to the
metal floor
frank sat up and swung his legs over the
side of his bunk
he scratched the back of his neck and
ran his fingers over the salt and pepper
stubble on his chin
see i'm up he called out do i at least
have time to shower
and shave of course just don't dawdle
yes mother his sly smile gave away that
he wasn't as annoyed as he put on
i'll see you soon said the voice and
with a slight crackling the pa
system went silent frank stood up from
the bed
feeling his bones creak and crack as he
did so
he stretched his arms out wide and let
out a long sigh
he shuffled to a mirror over a small
metal sink across from the bunk
giving an expressionless look into the
mirror his face appeared smooth
almost pristine but for the stubble in
many ways it was still the face of a
young man
however when he proceeded to smile and
work his mouth in a few different shapes
the many lines and wrinkles became
immediately apparent the depth of the
lines betrayed the fact that he was
much older than he appeared at first
glance
frank peeled off the white tank top and
brown shorts he'd slept in
and stepped into the shower stall once
inside he lazily jabbed at a purple
button and water began cascading down on
him from the ceiling
it was warm and came down in thick
streams
as he showered the temperature of the
water increased and the intensity of the
streams diminished
in accordance with his pre-programmed
preferences
it only took a small dollop of shampoo
to watch to wash his cro
closely cropped hair frank cleansed
himself fairly quickly
but the relaxing feel of the water kept
him from leaving the shower stall
he tilted his head upward to let the
water droplets hit his face
at this point in the program the water
came down in more of a misting rain
rather than the streams it had been
earlier
suddenly the mist was replaced by
powerful jets of water which blasted the
naked man at near freezing temperatures
he screeched and left out of the shower
god
damn it mel he called out his teeth
chattering as he groped for his towel
the pa system popped back to life and
the voice had a smugness about it
i told you not to dawdle one of these
days frank muttered as he tossed the wet
towel onto the edge of the sink and
started to rummage through drawers for
clothes
so you keep saying said mel knowingly
there was a slight snicker over the pa
before the system was switched off again
frank pulled on a tight gray t-shirt
which was admittedly a touch too small
that was the idea though because it
showed off the body he'd worked hard to
maintain
he also put on a pair of black pants and
laced up faded
black leather boots
uh hold on i'm getting uh
i'm getting an alert here
it's not receiving anything to maintain
smooth streaming what is going on
am i buffering for anybody
sorry to stop suddenly just
trying to see if this thing is lying to
me
about there being an issue or not
um
stream says why why why why
huh no all good okay
all right good to know sorry i'm sorry
for the interruption
so going back uh a paragraph
one of these days frank muttered as he
tossed the wet towel onto the edge of
the sink and started to rummage through
the drawers for clothes
so you keep saying said mel knowingly
there was a slight snicker over the pa
system before it was switched off again
frank pulled on a tight gray t-shirt
which was admittedly a touch too small
that was the idea though because it
showed off the body he'd worked hard to
maintain
he put on a pair of black pants and
laced up faded black leather boots
he took another glance's face in the
mirror and then at the clock on the wall
if he took the time to shave
mel would probably insist that he
wouldn't have time for breakfast
he sighed as he looked at his two-day
growth he resigned himself to his
slightly unkempt appearance
and turned to leave the sliding metal
door stood rigid as he approached
until he delivered a rough kick to the
wall next to the doorway
after a clanking sound the door slid
open
frank clomped his way down the metal
corridor lights flicking
on a few feet ahead of him as he went
and then turning off again once he was
more than a few feet past them
he didn't really need the lights he
could navigate blindfolded by now
however the courtesy of it still made
him smile
he stopped about halfway down the
corridor turned and gave another rough
kick to a metal door
the door slid open and frank stepped
into the tiny dining room
it was done up with a few more homie
touches than the utilitarian metal work
that made up most of the vessel
the walls were pristine white with
images of nature scenes
changed daily today it was a jungle
theme with paintings of a waterfall
a massive and expansive tree as seen
from below
and a view from above the canopy frank
hadn't been treated to a scene this
vibrantly green in a while it was a nice
change of pace from the animal portraits
he'd been viewing of late
frank sat at a small plastic table
colored to resemble wood
his chair was positioned so that he was
facing the one wall that didn't have a
picture
there was a small hatch and some lights
and switches above that
he gave a rhythmic knock on the table
the lights flashed to light
to life in shifting colors as though
they were cycling through the rainbow
good morning frankie my boy came a voice
out of a speaker located in the midst of
the flashing lights
morning murray replied frank what you
got for me today
for you buddy i can do you up a nice
scramble and hash
said the voice in a way best described
as overly friendly
works for me said frank as he leaned
back in his chair there was a series of
worse and clunks from the wall
it took less less than a minute for the
machine to assemble that morning's
protein supplement into the shape and
flavor
of scrambled eggs paired with a potato
and sausage hash
breakfast had become frank's favorite
meal if for no other reason than the
food processing unit had nailed down
eggs and simple meats better than the
more complex entrees
it served him for lunches or dinners the
whirring stopped and then there was a
clear ringing like a counter bell at an
old-fashioned diner
order up came the friendly voice from
the wall the hatch opened up and a tray
was thrust forward
on the tray was a plate with a sizeable
portion of eggs
and hash as well as a knife and fork
frank slid the
plate off the tray which which quickly
retracted back into the wall with a
metallic clank
i don't suppose there's any coffee left
he asked as he picked up the fork and
set the knife to the side
sorry buddy replied murray i could do
you some tea
earl grey maybe frank grimaced
he'd been pushing the limits on how long
he could stay out on patrol
the biggest annoyance annoyance about
doing this was running short on things
the processor couldn't copy
the machine was never very good with
liquids no matter how much he tinkered
with it
he had never cared for tea but he knew
he could use a little something to get
him going and a strong tea was better
than nothing
sure just not too hot this time he said
between bites of his breakfast
i don't have time to wait for it to cool
i know
mel told me not to let you linger here
too long said murray over the renewed
whirring from behind the hatch
there was another single ring in the
hatch opened once more producing a
plastic cup with warm tea
frank took the cup and down the entire
thing hoping the flavor wouldn't linger
on his tongue
he made a face as he swallowed he then
went to work on the eggs and hash
letting the strong flavor of the sausage
cleanse his palate
it only took him a few minutes to finish
off the food after which he dumped the
plate utensils and the plastic cup in a
bin
which had slid out from the wall near
his feet he headed down the metal hall
towards the circular hatchway at the end
it spiraled open as he approached
and the pleasant voice was heard again
hey handsome
said mel hey gorgeous replied frank as
he entered
being in the cockpit was like being on
the inside of a ball
the walls were rounded and smooth on all
sides apart from the lines of rivets
holding the panels in place
he descended a short set of stairs that
led from the door
and brought him to an empty chair at the
bottom of the spherical room
it was the only piece of furniture in
the cockpit
he sat in the chair and proceeded to
strap himself in with the attached
harness
did i miss anything did i miss anything
during the night
mel's voice rang out again coming
through much clearer in here than over
the general pa system
it emanated from all parts of the curved
walls and gave the soft and gentle voice
an
enveloping quality not too much really
the westbrook nebula looked particularly
lovely but i knew you wouldn't want to
be woken up
just for that i don't know replied frank
there was silence from mel that
eventually prompted him to admit
yeah okay you're right don't act like i
don't
know you mel's voice chided once frank
had finished
strapping himself into the chair he
flicked a switch
that disengaged the artificial gravity
in the cockpit the chair floated up from
the floor
until it reached the exact center of the
room once there it was held in place by
a static field
which kept it from fleet from free
floating around aimlessly
he placed his hand over a control ball
on the left armrest
he rotated it and the chair turned and
flipped about in the air in conjunction
with his hand motions
having tested the calibration he was
ready for the day
all right mel bring it up a series of
holographic screens flickered to life on
all sides of frank
he rotated the chair in a spiraling
fashion so he could examine each readout
and turn
starting from the top and circling his
way down the information ranged from
detailed schematics of the engine to a
navigational chart of the ship's patrol
route
frank paid close attention to some of
the readouts and
routine looking good girl looking
very good frank said thank you said mel
anything i'm missing frank asses he
finished his survey of the daily
readouts
we have an unidentified object about
half a parsec out
replied mel you made a rock he grumbled
in response
the long range readouts are inconclusive
and we're too far out for a visual
confirmation
mel shot back sweetie they're always
rocks he said
rocks with bits in them we don't
recognize sometimes
sure but still rocks
where's your sense of adventure frank
she asked with a slight pout in her
voice
i lost it after the 78th rock he replied
i don't suppose you want to alter course
to get a better look than
mel asked frank didn't reply at first
he let the question hang in the air for
a moment then he flicked a switch on the
right arm of the chair and the
navigation screen
moved closer with the holographic
display within arm's length frank
reached out and adjusted the thrusters
on the ship
setting a new heading that would bring
it close enough to the uo
for mel to get a better read on it thank
you frank
came mel's voice in the room again
bubbly and filled with excitement
you're welcome he said quietly with a
smile on his face
with the new destination set he righted
the chair and reinstated the artificial
gravity
the gravity came back on gradually so
the chair was gently lowered into place
rather than falling like a stone once
the chair landed he unstrapped himself
and headed up the stairs out of the
cockpit the holographic readouts were
still up and he had to walk through one
of them to reach the stairs
keep your eyes on it let me know when
we're close enough to confirm that it's
just
another rock he said as he reached the
circular hatchway
someday it's going to be something
amazing and
you'll be sorry mel sang out
frank didn't answer but as the hatchway
opened and he stepped through it he
kissed the first two fingers on his
right hand
and touched those fingers to the wall
behind him the data on the holographic
display
shifted and flitted about as mel took
over basic functions
to prepare the sensors for a closer look
at the uo
having set course at the most energy
efficient pace
frank knew it would be about an hour
before the ship would be in range of the
most powerful sensors
with that in mind he headed back down
the hallway he paused in front of the
gym
and weighed the merit of keeping in
shape against the added drain on food
and water
he opted to skip it at least for today
and he took the next door instead
this brought him to the entertainment
room it was a little more than a sunken
chair
pointed at a large screen frank slumped
into the softly cushioned chair and
flicked a switch on the armrest
the screen shot to life with swirling
colors and an energetic voice came out
of the sound system
hey there frank no workout today
not today eddie frank side what's on tap
well that depends
said eddie what kind of mood are we in
what can we do in the way of new yet
pleasantly familiar inquired frank
well i've been reconfiguring the
corrupted files and was able to dredge
up a bit more of that old doctor who
show for you
offered eddie frank scratched his
stubbly chin and chin
as he contemplated the offer sounds good
wait
which doctor 17th said eddie
frank shrugged yeah sure why not he
settled a bit more into the chair as the
familiar opening credits began to play
on the screen
halfway through the theme song the image
suddenly froze and the sound cut out
mel's voice came in through the through
the room sound system
frank frank sighed and hung his head a
little bit but after a deep breath he
perked up again
what is it darling i was running a
routine check on the research grade
sensor systems and some of them keep
phasing in and out
can you take a look at the wiring for me
her voice had a slight sense of pleading
to it and he couldn't help but smile
she knew he found the way she asked for
favors adorable and
she always used it to her advantage
sure thing he got up out of his chair
with a groan the entertainment room
powered down as he exited
frank made a quick stop back at his
sleeping quarters to grab a tool kit
and soon after he was unscrewing a panel
near the floor in the hallway
once the panel was removed he scooted on
his stomach into the crawl space
leaving his lower half sticking out he
set up a small portable light and took a
quick look at the inner workings of the
sensor array
as mel had said several of the high-end
short-range
sensors were kicking off and on
sporadically he'd been skimping on the
routine maintenance of late and he was
regretting it now
can you hear me mel he called out mel
wasn't equipped with sound detection in
the repair shafts
so he had to say it loud enough that it
could be heard out in the hallway
i hear you frank nice buns by the way
mel said in a saucy tone frank chuckled
thanks darling i'm gonna need you to
shut down the outer sensor feel for a
few minutes i don't need that thing's
live wires zapping me while i get this
worked out no problem replied mel
there was a change in tone in the
general hum of the ship as some of the
sensor systems were powered down
frank fished some tools out of his kit
and began to fiddle with the sensor
system
whistling as he did the whistle echoed
in the tight shafts and drifted down the
hallway
frank yama
what happens when they retire me he
paused in his work
where'd that come from he asked
i don't know k mel's voice from the
hallway
this is our eighth tour i'm sure there
must be newer models available by now
baby i wouldn't want to be out here with
anybody else replied frank they couldn't
pay me enough i'm surprised they keep
sending you out here
said mel aren't you overdue for
retirement yourself
she paused before adding old man
frank smirked hey don't give me any of
your lip i'm as solid as i ever was
oh i can see that mel responded in a
shamelessly flirty tone
frank laughed and finished his
adjustments he then scooted backward out
of the repair shaft
all right darling that should do it
how's it look for you
there was a pause as mel cross checked
and tested the repaired sensor
array when her voice came back over the
speaker it was bright and cheerful
perfect what would i do without you
if i have my way you'll never have to
find out
frank kissed his fingers once more and
pressed them to the metal wall
we'll be close enough for you to check
out that you owe soon keep me posted
alright
you know i will mel said her voice went
silent but frank was able to detect the
minute change in the hum of the ship as
the sensors he just repaired were fully
powered up and prepped
he wandered back into the entertainment
room which lit up again at his presence
and slumped into the chair once more
alright eddie keep it going as the
images on the screen resumed their
movement
and the sound came back on frank found
himself yawning
he was tired more often these days
normally he'd fight it off but
with mel occupied for at least the next
hour he let the comfort of the chair
overwhelm him overwhelm him and he
closed his eyes
when he was woken up by a sudden jolt
that shuttered across the entire ship
frank almost tumbled out of the chair as
he picked himself up he called out
mel what was that there was no response
mel the lights in the room flickered
silently
but no answer came over the pa system
mel
frank ran to the door of the
entertainment room which failed to open
as he approached
don wake up i need you the lights in the
room took on a red hue
as the independently powered defense
offense network
came online and assumed control of the
ship's major functions
a deep voice came over the speaker's
state nature of emergency
probable collision possible attack high
alert and update status on an ongoing
basis frank grunted out as he pried open
the door with his bare
hands the lights in the hallway had gone
red frank dash for the cockpit
mel please tell me you can hear me a
voice came over the speakers
impact from an unknown source has
rendered primary ai
unstable the voice was mels
but it was hollow mechanical and without
a hint
of emotion no
frank cried out as he reached the
cockpit he felt a glimmer of hope when
the cockpit door spiraled open
albeit in a stuttering fashion entering
the spherical room
frank saw that all the holographic
displays were out and there was a
sizeable dent jutting inward on the port
side of the normally smooth concave wall
he leapt down the stairs to a service
panel he grabbed the panel and grunted
as he peeled back the thin metal alloy
that covered this section of the ship's
inner workings
sparks flew in frank's face and the
light of the systems he just uncovered
were much
dimmer than they should have been oh god
mel hang on baby
he ran back to the hall for his tools
which was still on the floor by the
service shaft
they'd been scattered by the impact but
he quickly gathered up what he needed
and dashed back to the cockpit
as he began to work furiously at
reconnecting electronic synapses and
keeping the power flow consistent
the deep voice of dawn came over the
speakers again
threat has passed no sign of additional
hazardous objects
frank kept his eye on what he was doing
as he barked out orders override
navigation protocols and redirect back
to destination zero i can't fix her out
here
the ship's engines fired up and started
to propel the vessel to its new
destination
frank couldn't complete the repairs on
the damage he was seeing
but with enough work he could keep mel's
internal system from degrading until he
could do a full workup
he wiped sweat off his brow as he
switched tools and kept working
dawn he hollered out the deep voice
kicked in
yes frank what the hell hit us
unspecialized
unspecified geological debris space junk
why didn't we see it
frank asked is one of the connections he
was trying to repair sparked and fizzled
out in his hand
mid-range scanners were online however
the outer sensor field was not
active what why not a recording of
frank's own voice
rang out through the room thanks darling
i'm gonna need you to shut down the
outer sensor field for a few minutes i
don't need that thing zapping me while i
get this worked out
his heart sank as he realized he hadn't
turned the sensor field back on after
he'd finished his earlier repairs
mel was fully capable of running things
on her own at this point she could even
reverse a direct order from frank
without his permission if she wanted to
however she would often wait for his
go-ahead out of a sense of etiquette
and he knew that she'd been waiting for
permission to turn the sensors on again
or maybe in her excitement she hadn't
realized they needed to be turned back
on
he'd forgotten one thing and now
he might lose her kick in the
afterburners
the monotone voice of mel came over the
speakers
safety override without the primary ai
in command of navigation functions this
is not an advisable course of action
just do it bellowed frank
he saw one of the core synaptic junction
start to fade and he hastily licked his
fingers and pinched the connection
there was a jolt and he cringed from the
shock as the synapse reasserted itself
for the time being
the ship began to shake and shudder as
the afterburners kicked in
and rocketed the vessel back to its
point of origin at speeds frank had
never traveled before even when the ship
was brand new
he needed to get back as quickly as
possible he wasn't sure how long he
could keep mel's ai from unraveling
he dug a small override remote out of
his toolkit it had never been used
because the voice command had never been
offline before
frank fiddled with it while keeping one
eye on the pulsing light of the
electronic synapses
with some adjustments he was able to
render the metal wall in front of him
transparent
outside the stars planets and indeed all
of space
appeared to be bending around the ship
it helped him keep his cool being able
to see the progress they were making
this allowed him to concentrate more
fully on keeping mel
alive sometime later as the ship neared
its destination
just being able to see the stars zoom
past wasn't enough
frank was desperate to talk to mel to
know that
she was still functional he was
terrified to try and reactivate her in
this state
but he had to know that she wasn't
already gone he took the time to try and
secure the flickering synapses as best
he could
he adjusted the manual remote so that
her only her most basic functions would
come online
and she wouldn't have to contend with
excess data
frank closed his eyes and whispered
please he pressed a button on the remote
there was a whirring that emanated from
the walls around him
and then he heard a scratchy trembling
voice
frank
sorry aunt it took everything he had to
hold back the tears he took a deep
breath
before replying hey there baby
i'm missing a lot of functions what
happened
we were hit replied frank he rubbed a
hand on the smooth walls of the cockpit
as he spoke
it's okay though we're headed back
you're gonna be fine
my my
my sh baby don't strain yourself he
urged
there was a pause my scan
of the you oh
what about it mel what'd you find didn't
finish but my new traces of plant matter
detected mel said with audible
difficulty
this time he couldn't stop the tears
rolling down his cheeks
that's wonderful baby see you have to
hold on so you can tell me i told you so
really rub my face in it
living plant matter mel concluded
even with her strained voice there was a
sense of excitement
i'm sorry i ever doubted you just hang
on we're almost there
frank pleaded uplink
signal established said mel uplink what
uplink
preparing for data upload from
destination
zero frank's eyes went wide with panic
later baby you need to save your
strength and with that he flicked her
off as if she was nothing more than a
light switch
god damn you charlie he growled
he glanced down feverishly at the
synapses and saw that they were still
holding
looking out through the transparent wall
he could see the blue and green specter
of earth
looming large and the ship would soon
hit the atmosphere
frank begrudgingly left the panel of
circuitry to which he'd been tending for
the past few hours
and went to the chair he gritted his
teeth as he strapped himself
in dawn are you still running the show
the deep and resonating voice came over
the speakers
yes frank i need manual piloting for the
for the descent with that command a
floor plate slid to the side and a panel
with buttons and controls
rose out of the floor to the level of
frank's hands he gripped the control
sticks tightly as the ship hit the
atmosphere
and shook about violently he started to
sweat as the temperature in the cockpit
rose the damage from the impact had
compromised the heat shield but all he
could do at this point was hope that it
held
he gripped the controls with his until
his knuckles turned white
he shook some of the sweat from his face
and it sizzled as it hit the metal floor
he craned his neck to see that mel
synapses were still lit
the retro rockets kicked in and the
descent of the ship began to slow
frank took full control and aimed the
vessel at a city
in the center of the of a sea of
spire-like buildings was a large
circular piece of flat land
he continued to slow the speed of the
descent and was soon touching down
gently on the hard ground the engines
hadn't even fully powered down before he
was
before he had unstrapped himself and was
descending out of a round escape hatch
in the corridor
he dropped a few feet to the ground
around him the outer edges of the circle
on which he'd landed
were folding upwards to form a metal
dome over the parked ship
frank wasted no time in heading toward
the causeway that would take him to the
supply depot
he walked with forceful purpose as the
dome became
completely sealed above his head he was
just reaching the causeway
a voice reverberated throughout the dome
hello
frank shut up charlie frank snapped i
don't want to talk to you
that brought a silence to the dome once
in the causeway frank started jogging to
the supply depot
the causeway was enclosed in transparent
metal which allowed a view of the
buildings outside
though some of the lights of the city
were lit there was no movement
there were no vehicles on the roads no
people on the sidewalks
not even a silhouette and a window the
roads themselves were beginning to crack
as grass had broken through at some
points frank paid this view no mind
he'd seen it before and it hadn't gotten
any better
once in the supply depot he began
loading up a hand truck
with equipment and a memory storage unit
so he could be sure mel would be
safely stored while he worked on the
ship as he wheeled it all back down the
causeway
charlie's voice embellished him once
more
if it is your intention to do all
repairs yourself to spite me
i fear that you may not be able to
properly restore her
frank gritted his teeth what hurt most
was that he knew the melody's voice
coming at him from all sides was right
i only wish to help frank fine
frank said it with a defeated tone but
stick to the physical damage i don't
want you
or any of your little minions touching
her processors or her memory do
you understand yes frank
as he passed from the caused way into
the dome once more
he was joined by service robots of
varying sizes which were rising out of
the floor all around
most were box-shaped and very
utilitarian designed for function
and not style by the time he reached the
ship some of them had already set to
work assessing the damage out in the
outer hull
he knew they could do these repairs
better and faster than he ever could but
it still made him uneasy
frank ran his fingers along the weather
beaten edge of the ship
and across the faded designation
melbourne
ii he pulled himself back into the hatch
from which he left the ship
and was just finishing hauling up the
supplies that he'd gathered when
charlie's
voice came in through the ship's pa
system frank
i would like to talk to you i told you
to stay
out frank yelled i have not infiltrated
any aspect of mel's inner workings
i have only asked ces the public address
system
frank took a breath and started to drag
the boxes of tools and supplies to the
cockpit
you can't have her charlie he grunted
through gritted teeth
as he reached the control room there
were sparks firing up around the large
dent as the robots outside removed
certain small sections with surgical
precision
frank reached the panel he'd opened
before and began to unpack the equipment
he brought in
i cannot force you to give her up frank
and tone charlie's gentle and soothing
voice
but i would ask that you think of more
than yourself
who else is left for me to think of
frank shot back
there was a pause from charlie and a
slight hum that was almost like a human
sigh
it is true the more time that passes
without any other stragglers
returning increases the likelihood that
you are
all that remains i was tasked with the
preservation of the human race
and at that i failed but i can still
preserve their memory
save some piece of what made the species
special
frank hooked up the remote memory
storage to the flickering synapses
so that he could relay mel's ai into it
and safely work on reestablishing the
connections without fear of losing her
why does it have to be her
because you're going to die frank said
charlie plainly
i will do all that i can for you and
your comfort but you will not last
forever
i understand your desire to maintain
your routine
but you may not even last another tour i
cannot save you
but i can save her preserve her
forever but why
her she's not the only one with a
personality why can't you take
murray or eddie the anger was draining
from his voice and was rapidly being
replaced by a sense of melancholy
and loss their personalities are
rudimentary
charlie pointed out they never evolved
beyond the basic parameters you
programmed into them
mel is different and you know that
her ability to learn combined with
prolonged exposure and discourse with
you
gave her more than a programmed
personality
her time with you has given her some of
those uniquely human traits
and something that may even be
approximate to emotions
these grew out of experience i cannot
recreate them through ones and zeros
and copying her base code will not carry
them over
she is unique she has a spark of
humanity about her which can
and should be preserved
by this point a few of the smaller
service robots had entered the ship and
were trundling down the control room
stairs to address the damaged sections
from the inside
frank ignored them and stayed bent over
the open panel
there was a spark as he inserted a
replacement piece and he shot his hand
up from the electrical
jolt i can have one of the servicers do
that
charlie offered not a chance
you do not trust me charlie observed not
after that uplink stunt you tried to
pull frank said as he finished up the
link he was working on
i only intended to inform her of the
current planetary status
well she doesn't need to know frank
yelled
there was a pause before charlie spoke
again
i would never take her from you against
your wishes frank
but she is more than an operating system
now
she has agency beyond anything ever
designed for her
she has a right to know and you have
been keeping it from her for too long
frank put down his tools and hung his
head in shame
if she knew then she'd leave me
there was a time when that would have
been certain charlie pointed out
but you do not know that anymore and
neither do i
before she would have concurred with my
logic that her being downloaded in full
and preserved here
is the best course of action but she is
different now
she has opinions she has desires
that changes everything it is the reason
i cannot trust you to simply leave
instructions for her
to return should you die while on tour
we do not know how she will react to
your death
it could break her heart and she may
never come back on her own
frank rubbed his eyes and bent down low
to double check the work he done
charlie continued i do not know if she
will choose to be downloaded and
preserved
but i do feel that she should have the
power to make that choice for herself
you are denying her that frank's
response came out as
meek and ashamed i don't think
i could take it if she didn't choose me
he glanced over to where the room had
been dented from the impact
service robots were finishing up and the
surface was once again pristine
and smooth i've taken the liberty of
refueling her and a fresh complement of
stores and supplies will be loaded in
shortly
said charlie i know you do not like me
frank
but i can only do what is best for you
as your permissions allow
i think of myself as your friend but i
am still what i was designed
and will always remain as much
my time with humans was never as
intimate as that which you have shared
with mel
i am not like her
you do just fine charlie frank says as
he reloaded mel stored
ai from the remote before disconnecting
it
thank you frank frank proceeded to go
through the pre-flight checklist with
charlie
as the last of the ship's stores were
loaded once they were finished
he strapped himself into the pilot seat
once more and took hold of the manual
flight sticks
charlie's voice came through one last
time
i hope that i will see you again but if
not
i wish you well frank flicked a switch
and both the front and top of the
spherical cockpit became transparent
he could see the dome cracking open to
allow him to ascend back into space
later charlie once the dome had fully
receded frank fired up the engines and
the ship rocketed straight upwards
there was a slight shake on to the deck
as it exited the atmosphere
but it was possibly the smoothest
takeoff since the vessel had first been
launched
as the ship reached the outer edges of
charlie's primary supervision field
his voice came over the pa system please
tell her frank frank sighed and set the
autopilot course for the region of space
from which
he'd come he unstrapped himself from the
pilot's chair
and looked around the empty sphere he
took a deep breath
reboot primary ai he closed his eyes
and held his breath as a new whirring
sound joined the other humming systems
within the ship
from behind his eyelids he thought he
detected additional sources of light
flicking on the cockpit but he didn't
dare open his eyes to confirm this
frank said mel her voice was pleasant
though puzzled frank opened his eyes and
the holographic screens had all flicked
on and were hovering around the room
he clapped his hands together and let
out a sharp laugh
are you all right asked mel quizzically
frank wiped tears from his eyes
yeah baby i'm fine how are you
there was a pause while mel ran an
internal diagnostic
i appear to have been offline for a
little bit i've got some scrambled data
what happened frank was running his hand
along the smooth inner walls of the
cockpit
he was practically caressing them we had
a close call
but it's okay now it looks like i was
prying for an upload from the
destination zero mainframe
was charlie trying to upgrade me mel
asked
no baby just a little data
reconfiguration frank replied
we'll do it later are you sure yeah
do you want me to remind you she asked
no
don't worry about it right now let's see
if we can find that uo again
oh my goodness i'd almost forgotten it
was amazing frank wait until you see it
mel was practically squealing with
excitement
can't wait for you to show me frank's
side the holographic screens were alive
and buzzing as she configured the data
she'd gathered before
and prepared to find the uo once again
frank decided
it was best to let her prepare on her
own he'd only get in the way
he walked up the stairs that led out of
the cockpit
the hatchway spiraled open he kissed the
first two fingers on his right hand
and touched them to the wall as he
stepped through
okay
i i hope um people actually got
enjoyment out of that that was
that was admittedly incredibly
self-indulgent
on my part um
that story i don't like i don't know if
anyone has questions about it or
um or thoughts or anything else but
i've um
i first conceived of that story a long
long long time ago um
[Music]
sort of tinkered with it uh
for a while and um
i'm i'm quite happy with that one
oh good good thank you all
that was wild oh nice
[Laughter]
uh like the thing is i couldn't um
i couldn't tell you like the the core
pitch of what it was
before i started because it would have
given too much of the game away
um because the the whole thing started
from
me trying to come up with uh
with my take on
you know the last human being alive i
give it the highest score i give
7.9 out of 10. thank you very much
uh
that was fantastic uh to be honest since
nobody's picked it up changed frank to
glitz from doctor who and have mel be
named after mel bush and you might
get into doctor who anthology ah
the voice over was good oh good that's a
that's a relief to hear
um
would you say a time lord can come under
genderless i don't see why not
uh i wonder what happened to everyone
it's a good mix of sweet and melancholy
i figured that like there would be some
people who would wonder like
what happened why is frank the last
person alive
and uh the honest answer
is i don't know because it doesn't
matter
um there are some writers who get very
into um kind of
exploring every nook of what it is that
they've created
i'm not that kind of writer i only
have answers to questions that i need to
know
in order to write the story that i want
to do
but for the story that i wanted to do
which is about frank and about mel
um oh crap am i buffering
ack come on
all right all right there it seems to be
fine
um so
for for the story that i wanted to do
which is about frank and about mel
it didn't matter what
the cause of it was and like i early on
i had very
briefly um considered just for my own
edification figuring out what it was but
then i realized
trying to close all the logical
loopholes of
how it managed to wipe out not only
all life on earth but that frank was the
only
um you know remaining human even given
that they have the power of space travel
like it doesn't matter what it was and
me trying to figure out i would have
driven myself
nuts for something that ultimately did
not matter um
for what i was doing but
um i'm glad people enjoyed it i'm glad
that many people stuck around
um and indulged me i was kind of
expecting to come back and have like
15 people left in the chat um
what secret is frank keeping from mount
i was i
was worried about that um not coming
through clearly because i did not lay
that out
100 it is implied though frank has not
told mel that
he is the last human alive she doesn't
know
the planet is dead um and
he is afraid that if she knew
she'd do what charlie wants which is to
take her out of the ship and preserve
her and
he he can't
stand the uh he he can't open
himself up to the possibility
that she might not choose him
there is no amount
of self-assuredness that will ever make
him comfortable
exposing himself to that possibility
uh so i am actually
if i'm gonna keep this going uh i
need to go use the bathroom so um
you can admire my shelves uh for a few
minutes
i'll be back shortly i also need to
stretch my back
ah cause i'm old
you
ah okay
oh thank you um
mickeleen oh not sure on pronunciation
but thank you
very very much that is a very cute fox
and another yeah
love it
uh let me get those added and i need to
check the
um the paypal so give me a second here
just scrolling back up through making
sure i didn't miss
any super chats yeah i don't think i did
ah
and let me check the paypal
see how that's going
come on wake up you darn thing
you ever have an app just seem like it's
um
on vacation come on wake up
well that was quick well
it it's have to be a lengthy process ah
know what i could use though are we
gonna do more mad libs yes there will be
more mad libs and i'm also going to
um put myself at
technological risk
um by attempting to
play um like some of the very early
scripted videos from the channel and
have it um serve kind of like a um
oh we got a little more on the paypal
let me
get that moved um it'll serve as kind of
a director's commentary
um assuming that i i get it to work
which we'll see given my luck
but salute
and oh this one came
with a note wishing you all the best
thank you
watching the stream an hour later i hope
future you is doing well
uh future you future you future me
uh is doing not too badly
uh let's see we're almost at a quarter
uh which honestly if we hit that i will
be i will be
ecstatic um
oh so just stretching my back a little
bit
uh was in my car yesterday in the song
fat bottom girls came on i immediately
thought of you
thank you now i think it's because i've
said it's one of my favorite queen songs
which so you know valid
absolutely valid um
so i'm just checking to see if there's
anything else i missed no
and yep got that cool
ah
so i am actually not even
in the window i meant to be in there we
go
all right let me see if i can get
this working because
um i feel
fairly confident
when i say that pretty much
nobody has um
[Music]
watched my very early
scripted shorts that were actually the
birth of this channel
uh would you ever do a burlesque number
on the song fat bottom girls
probably not because i like i've seen
amazing um burlesque numbers to that
song and it
like i kind of feel like that is the um
that is the purview of people with a
body type that is not mine
and i kind of feel like they have more
business making use of that song than i
do
uh but let me get here and see
if i've got this going correctly
so hang on uh which what was this one
is this one it
so i did uh no that's not the one i want
as
uh whoops okay
move that i just i accidentally got rid
of the pie chart there for a minute
um oh it's this one i even
labeled it dumbass
so if i move that there
okay
okay
uh
see if oh good
so that works that has audio
okay cool
let's get that backed up to the
beginning again
and actually you know what
we're gonna put me in front of it and
just shrink me
down and stick me off on the side where
i belong
let's see if that comes through all
right
and then uh
this is like i i enjoy going back and
and looking at these
um these old videos again because that
like they are
such a different format and they are so
completely different
um from anything i do now
it it's it's almost jarring
um but
let's see
okay
so this is the
very first uh video
that well it's technically not the very
first video that i
uploaded um because
there were like trailers for
what council of geeks originally was
which was a series of scripted shorts
um this was the first proper episode
that went
up though and this was titled the geeks
manifesto
so i'll have it go for a little bit and
then uh probably pause
and talk about it or actually uh
let me get a take for do you want me to
pause as i go or
would you like uh me to let it play the
whole way through it's only two minutes
and then go
back and like pause and talk about it
um so let me get a sense from the chat
which you'd rather have me do
and uh and we'll proceed in that fashion
uh i almost reached for the
um for the flask again i think i'll wait
a little longer before going to that
ah
let it play
is that the consensus whole thing okay
yeah i mean probably nobody's watched it
okay so we'll i'll let the whole thing
play
and then i will go back and sort of
stop and start and talk about it after
so here we go
i am a geek i'm not a nerd
i'm not a dork i'm not a dweeb
nerds are scholastic overachievers dorks
are perpetually awkward in social
situations
and dweebs well i think dweebs were
hunted to extinction in the 1980s but i
am a geek
and proud of it there are more of us out
there than you might think
a geek is someone with a passion for
something beyond a mere
interest or hobby they're the big ones
star trek geek
the video game geek the comic book geek
but it can be almost anything
knowing why she-hulk can change her form
at will while regular hulk can't
might not matter to you but it matters
to us
most people who geek out about things
want to live them
horror movie geeks like to make their
bloody home movies
a truly dedicated fantasy geek might
write a few harry potter fanfics and
somebody who is
a dungeon master who spends all of their
free time detailing a dungeons and
dragons campaign
drawing maps writing ancient texts and
accounting for
every possible outcome
well that person might be a serial
killer
my point is we care about these things
to a level that you may think unhealthy
but look around is it really so
different from the sports fan
the car nut the reality tv junkie
of course they'd never own up to being
geeks
but this isn't about them this is about
those of us that wear the label with
pride
you think you know what we're like you
think you can spot us
you think we wear star wars t-shirts
talk through our noses
and stay up late on the internet
chatting about how spider-man 3 was the
worst movie ever
you're wrong we blend in we live among
you and you don't even know it
we bag your groceries we do your taxes
we teach our children
we are geeks and we are everywhere
okay
i actually uh let me get
this back up here so
that that is so weird
to go back and uh and we're watch
so i suppose a couple of broad things um
to say in advance
um so that that was
made up uh yeah of a few
people who uh friends of mine and like a
lot of background people who were just
i i basically put a call out to the
people i knew in town like
hey who wants to be in this um
so it's funny like even even that
video is not
uh representative of what things were
but it was meant to be like an
introduction
uh to things it
it was it's it's just so weird going
back and watching so what i'll do
is i'll go through a little bit and i'll
pause and like give some specific
commentary
so you know opening with
um you know bits and shots uh of
various things and all of this stuff's
fine none of these are processed
it's all mine now this fellow i
am a geek i'm not a nerd ah
this is nathan now uh i met him
doing community theater uh in the town
where i live uh and he
i positioned him as being the
kind of default main character
in what were the original council of
geeks shorts because it was about three
friends but in my mind
uh he was the the central one
now this thing that he starts out with
this um
i'm a geek i'm not a nerd i'm not a dork
i'm not a dweeb that's actually
repurposed from like an
old old bit of stand-up that i had
um now the original
plan for this um
was was to have it be
one continuous shot
but nathan couldn't get it couldn't do
the whole thing
in one go so that's part of the reason
there's so many cutaways
i needed them so that i could stitch
together the takes of his
where he actually got his lines right
um so that that took a little work
um so not a dork
i'm not a dweeb nerds are scholastic
overachievers
dorks are perpetually awkward in social
situations
and dweebs well i think dweebs were
hunted to extinction in the 1980s but i
am a geek
and so like shots like this this is
actually from a
later episode and that is in fact
a video store there was still one
actually here's the thing i was like
there was still one in my town this
isn't even my town this is the next town
over
i called the video store in my town
about
shooting there and the guy who was an
owner was a jackass he basically wanted
me to just shoot an
advertisement for him he had no he that
was all he was interested in and he
didn't really get that i was trying to
do something and i was
you know he he just what he wanted i
wasn't going to give him
and so i ended up calling the video
store of the town next door
and they're still around at the time
video store they let me come in
and shoot um what's funny about that is
is that
neither of these video stores are still
in business
uh the one where you're seeing the shop
from that closed about a year after and
the
one in my town closed last year i think
um but we'll move on i'm proud of it
there are more of us out there than you
might think a geek is someone
with a uh so okay we've got a bunch of
random people here i'm not going to
identify them all
um by name or anything so we have you
know reading a
graphic is someone with a passion we've
got
excessive um very intense
uh playing of a video game that sort of
you know getting on there's something
beyond the mirror interest or hub
and okay so
i saw the question come up in the chat
already yes
that is my kid she was not even a year
old yet
and this is the one and
only time that you will see her on video
before she is 18 or at least on any
channel that i have control of
she doesn't have a ton of interest in
doing what i do
but like i if i really wanted to i could
probably
put together a conference like she she
could have been brought on to talk about
shira she loves shira but
like she's not old enough to un to
really understand the consequences
of being visible on a site like youtube
so i i'm not gonna do it but
yeah at uh at less than a year
knowing that she would not later be
identifiable by this image
and of course with permission of her
mother
that's my kiddo from a while back
and yes she is in fact sucking
on the end of riversong's sonic
screwdriver
oh they're the big ones
star trek geek the video game geek the
comic book geek
but it can be almost any wall okay all
right hold on i gotta back up just a
second
so klingon recipes uh that's me
that's me and a wig um and a dress that
i don't think i have anymore
um pretending to cook klingon recipes
and like going to the extra step of
actually boiling water
like i wasn't cooking anything but i did
get water boiling so that there was the
sort of steam coming up and it would
look more um
more believable less than a year old
she's already got a favorite sonic
screwdriver and a good choice too was
the first sonic i ever had
uh would go but it can be almost
anything knowing why she-hulk can change
her form
horror movie geeks like to make their
bloody home movies nicole
was playing kathy and okay i should back
up for that
okay so
yeah that's me in my basement or the the
basement um
of where i was living at the time and
that is my knife and
that's that one's not on the wall
because i don't have any way to mount
that one
uh so that that one stays packed away
because that one's uh that one's also
actually sharp uh
correction sucking on the top of a sonic
screwdriver not the end of but
like this is an end this is an end
they're both ends
i know what i'm doing um
okay anyways um so yeah this is me
pretending to be a horror geek which is
something that i very much am not
like i like horror fine but i i movie
geeks like to make their bloody home
movies
a truly dedicated fantasy geek might
have been
right a few harry potter fanfiction and
somebody toughed up there
um so we've got people in the background
playing magic the gathering dungeon
a lot of the stuff that you see uh like
on
the shelf behind me or that is normally
on the walls
um around here i like i spread
all over the house normally all that
stuff was confined to my den
um
or man cave if you must that i had at
the old house
um and and we spread it all over the
house for
this video so that it felt more
all-encompassing
their free time detailing and done okay
now
this sketch so it's it's implied by the
dialogue that these are
that this is a a dms sketch is in
dragon's campaign that and this
those are my sketches for the city map
and the world map for my novel which i
had the kickstarter for
um so like both of those i ended up
sending to the artists who i had do
the actual city map and the world map as
references for them to work off of
because i'd sketch this stuff out
drawing maps writing ancient
uh yeah and that's sex and accounting
for
everything possible that poster would be
outcome there
uh and of course we have the the scary
dnd player that's a regular that person
might be a serious
my point is we care about these things
to a level that you may think
unhealthy but look around is it really
so different
from the sports family i think every car
now we'll do one the reality
we'll come back of course they will
never own up to being geeks
but this is about this isn't actually
typical this is about those of us that
wear the label with pride
you think you know what we're like you
think you can spot us
do you think we wear star wars do you
know what we're like
ah come on
come on come on come on come on find it
ah son of a gun gotta find where the
label with pride yeah you think you know
there we go
okay so those that is not
those are my hands that is not my
artwork
i cannot draw like that those were drawn
by nathan's
brother and those actually get used in
the credits for a normal episode
this sort of being the pilot um
they're not uh they're they're not
features featured in here so this is the
the one way
um that i actually got them
in
uh let's see
i actually thought nerdtrotic was
multiple people at first for some reason
i mean given that name for the channel i
could have believed that
i've i've watched so few of those videos
that i
never would have um picked up still
wearing foamy t-shirts yes
yes that there's something that hasn't
changed what we're like um
you think you can spot us you think we
wear star wars t-shirts
talk through our noses and stay up late
on the internet chatting about how
spider-man 3 was the worst movie ever
worst movie
ever uh
i was totally never that geek and i i
had to be sure to put like the empty
um food containers around that
you're wrong we blend in we live among
you and you don't even know it
we bag your groceries we do your taxes
we teach our children
we are geeks and we are everywhere
see this is funny so again what was
supposed to happen
um what was supposed to happen for that
was uh
that i was um it was supposed to be one
continuous shot so what had happened
was while nathan was doing
the lines uh you know in the speech
they were all running out the back door
and and then uh to get to the backyard
for that last shot
of course it was all moot cause he never
got
he never got the lines down
uh
spider-man 3 was great no it wasn't
why is your content have to be so
entertaining i'm never going to finish
my homework i
because i'm because i need to raise
money if
dang well better be entertaining because
that's that is the basis by which i am
saying please
please give me money
speaking of which let's do a check see
if anything new has come in
oh yeah okay oh wait a minute
we've got oh we've got more
hold on
[Music]
okay hang on let me uh pop back on
i'm thinking we're gonna have to update
the thing yep uh yeah i'm gonna have to
update the thing
uh so i'll take a break for that and i
will update this
all right
all right this one came with a question
uh what are some tools you find helpful
in combating toxic fandom
uh the big one honestly it's the block
button
the block button is the
best tool that you have that's on
twitter
that's on tick tock that's a youtube
just removing people from
your site
that is gonna do so much
to help just
navigate things uh
because honestly that at its worst
when toxic elements of a fandom
find you that means that they
are going to bring others with them and
that you're probably going to get dog
piled by
anywhere from a dozen to a few hundred
people
and just being really liberal
swaying the ban hammer and honestly
sometimes it's kind of cathartic there
are times that i'll just
uh just kind of think oh hey
well that worked out well didn't it
you're gone don't have to see you
again uh
let's see this
and
uh and
okay that is folks that is actually
more than a quarter um doesn't look like
it on the pie chart i'm not sure why
it's looking skewed
should i change the style of chart
on that uh
let's let's un-3d it no like that should
be
that should be taking up more than it is
that's weird
don't know why that's doing that but
okay
whatever it still gives you a general
idea um we're more than a quarter raised
which again like honestly
that alone um super stoked
for that uh the maps kind of looked
dungeons and dragons
uh ask is uh your novel gonna be a game
as well just wondering
um for the novel to
to become a game okay here's the thing
it could the world would support
a game and there are definitely
roles and factions and
things that uh a dm
could definitely work with um
and i could even like come up with a
handful of character class
concepts from the um
[Music]
you know the uh the scientific field
researchers
to the alchemists to the marshals
like there's stuff to work with there
certainly
the thing is though i don't have the
skill set i do not have the ability to
construct
even like a supplementary um
you know thing to graft on to dnd like
uh like a specialized class or something
i don't have the skills to build that
if somebody ever did and wanted to talk
to me about it to
get like clearance and make it like
actually official in some way
i'd be totally down for talking about it
but
i don't have those skills only recently
learned that mrs octavius and spider-man
2 is mother gothel from tangled
really i did not know that
and i've clearly started breaking my um
i'm only gonna
answer questions that are um
done with super chats i've clearly
broken that now
i do need to check over on the discord
so let me do that real quick uh
let's see uh given in
a new adaptation of the stand is airing
i understand
i i understand do you have any king
adaptations you really
like i think you do not like the shining
correct
but perhaps you are a secret maximum
overdrive fan i've never seen maximum
overdrive
there are some that i like i like stand
by me
i like misery uh i like to room 1408
pretty well
um there are others but like i feel like
misery and stand by me are the
big ones that are
um really uh sort of the
the high end for
uh adaptations of his work in my opinion
your older stuff reminds me of old
school channel awesome you know what's
funny about that i didn't discover
channel awesome until well after i'd
stopped
making that stuff so i can't even claim
i was trying to copy them and i just
somehow ended up doing it anyway
um actually the general vibe um
that i was trying for was something more
akin to after hours uh
that the series on cracked
um
but yeah so here's
what i'm thinking looking at time
ah god i can't reach
things huh
i love stephen king but never got into
the stand
talking about the books though king
doesn't translate well into flicks
see the thing is i can't speak too much
on how well he does or doesn't adapt
because i've i've never finished reading
a stephen king
story sorry i just haven't
but i've certainly seen reviewers and
friends of mine point out that like you
know the way that he describes something
uh is a gets lost in translation in a
way
because he'll spend like a whole page
describing a desk
and a chair in a room
and when you translate that to a visual
medium
a full page of text becomes a literal
two-second
shot and the effect is very very very
very different
uh okay so here's what i'm thinking
i am going to
do one more mad lib
one more one more go at the bean boozled
and then we'll do one more
um
video uh from the early days of the
channel
and at that point i might
i might call it a day at that point or
call it a night
um because i think you know the way
these things go
the um
the the bulk of the contributions come
in
early uh and then they slow down from
there
so um at a certain point it it it helps
to know when to bow out
so that you don't start becoming you
know that that the cliche of the
desperate guy at the near the end of the
telephone come on we need you to help us
out here what will it take for you to
give us money
i don't want to become that so
oh god
we will end with my viewing doctor in
distress
fine but you gotta stick through
it so anyways
we're doing mad libs first
are you a jedi or a sith well my uh
my lightsaber is red
okay so let let's do another mad lib
folks
uh i'm gonna need an adjective
and a plural noun
do i like k-pop i don't know enough
k-pop to say whether or not i like it
most most of what i know of k-pop
uh is through tiny snippets of it
showing up on tick tock
that's kind of all i've got
uh do i have yes
oh boy there was too much excitement
over me watching
this darn thing okay
and i'm dropping this pencil again like
wait why didn't i get a better pencil
this this
this is pathetic
adjective singing whistling or humming
um
gangnam style slyly
[Music]
plural noun plural noun
all right i'm taking that not my doctor
youtubers i need an
adverb and
um another plural noun
ah thank you kate i saw that i commented
on that that
you know that it reminded you of the old
school channel awesome stuff which
obviously i don't watch channel awesome
anymore but i'll still take it as a
compliment
wolves jabberwock
taking jabberwocks
um
oh smuggly
nice uh i need a place and a noun
all right well okay someone said
buttocks i'm gonna grab that now because
the next one was gonna be parts of the
body
so we're going with that
strip club
uh
rock
i need a number and an adjective
was buttocks intended for place or noun
i took it for part of the body which was
coming up after
buttocks as a place
um
so i'm at uh number and adjective
42.69 nice
uh we're going 69 why not
oh two votes for 69. that works 69 and
nice noise see it's that
it's not nice it's noise uh i also need
an adjective
we got we got the number i need an
adjective beatboxing
now beatboxing is a verb
adjective menacingly
uh
effervescent
misspelling it but whatever i'll read it
right um i need a verb ending it oh
beatboxing you know what i've already
got a verb ending in i
and ing so i'll take that i need an
adjective i need two adjectives
to and to round this out
excuse me
can't you just tell i'm 14.
uh oh well i still have the brain of a
14 year old
sometimes beatbox like
dazzling i feel like that one's
come up before
[Music]
and
wet going with wet okay
here we go are folks ready for
a cyberman story
you will be upgraded
you will be upgraded
a meditatively robotic voice said as the
sound of several metallic
not my doctor youtubers crashed against
the ground
you will become like us
closing in smugly were the cyber
jabberwocks a race of cybernetically
altered jabberwocks
whose only goal was to conquer the strip
club
and enslave every rock from the sound of
clanging buttocks
there were at least 69 noise of them
approaching from all directions
you are effervescent the human race will
be
reborn as superior beings
the metallic beat boxing got louder as
the dazzling monsters closed in
if you are wet it said
you will be upgraded
i do enjoy that i probably i probably
enjoy that a little bit too much
playing the cyberman theme if i was
confident in my ability to
balance the sound levels i totally could
have had that play although that would
uh that would have gotten me clocked
with um
copyright again uh
oh well okay so let me
pull out another few of these things
uh let's uh okay now i've
done those what's some colors i haven't
done
i haven't done that haven't done that
and i haven't done that okay i'm gonna
regret this
now i swear if all three of these
also end up being the bad versions
then i'm i'm never touching a box of
this again
because like they they lie when they say
that there are good versions
so oh god all right we'll leave that one
for the last
oh whoops
i'm dropping stuff a lot tonight
ah okay so
all right we'll do that one second
because worst case isn't that bad on
that one so that'll be a
potential palette cleanser
this is either
buttered popcorn this is not a jelly
bean flavor that i am
particularly fond of or
it's rotten egg hi jessie
[Laughter]
oh thank you for bringing that to my
attention carolyn thank you jordan
vera thank you for inspiring me to write
again you seriously helped my mental
health and overall life thank you so
much
jordan that is wonderful to hear um
so okay
as i said this is either gonna be butter
popcorn
or rotten egg
that's buttered popcorn i think
oh
it's another one that like tricks you at
first and then it comes in on the back
end
well i also sing the doctor in distress
i can't it's copyrighted
when i do that i'm gonna i'm gonna have
to have some workarounds we'll
deal with that when we get there ah
ah okay so now i'm o for four
in terms of always getting the bad
version of these things oh
hi
you people are having too much fun at my
expense okay
so this one is either lime
or lawn clippings i'm not too worried
about lime
lawn clippings and i like lime so like i
said this is kind of the palette
cleanser
that is actually lime there is no
mistaking lime
for lawn clippings okay so that's one
one out of five
was not the bad version of what it could
have been
uh
oh i'm going to prep
a
pallet cleanser for this next one
you can only choose one aaron bird or
angelica skyler angelica easily
burr's a very interesting character but
like
on tick-tock a while back i did like
ranking
the the character the main characters
from
um hamilton in order of
uh whether or not i think they'd be good
in bed angelica scored quite
high burr did pretty good he was upper
half but angelica way above him
okay so this
oh god
the black one this
is either going to be
licorice which i actually
like i know lots of people don't i
actually like licorice
or skunk spray
oh god
oh thank you jack for giving me a reason
to delay this
have you ever seen or will you watch the
ballot of russell
and julie it was a musical homage to
russell t davies
and julie gardner by john barrowman
david tennant and catherine tate
i hadn't even heard of this
i mean i'm curious now
um but no i uh i was not
familiar with that at all
yeah well i'm gonna try i'm gonna try
and toy with this uh
thing and try and get it to read closer
to what what it should be
hang on uh
there we go that is more what it should
be looking like
okay uh and also thank you very much for
that donation i greatly appreciate it
it's not a lose-lose either way jackie
jet jeky
jessie i like licorice
okay
oh god oh that's immediate oh it is oh
god like it was in my mouth but i can
smell it in my nose
oh dear god
oh god
just breathing out it's like it's coated
the back of my throat and like i breathe
out
and the air comes up my airways and like
is picking up remnants of it so it's
like it's in my nose
oh jesus
whoever came up with that one
i hope you step on a lego brick
oh
oh and it's it's it's
oh god it's still lingering oh god
oh oh
numb the pain
uh angelica skyler or hercules mulligan
uh you already know who i would choose
so if you're asking me
when i did my ranking of who i think
hey
who i think um would be better in bed
[Music]
what if doom [ __ ] was a classic era
doctor who villain
he'd be from one of the stories nobody
likes
thank you very much bookworm if you had
to pick a favorite character from
torchwood beside
jack who would you pick oh that's
actually
hard because i don't like most of the
characters from
torchwood um
i mean like
if we're going outside the scope of the
team then it would be
um god i can't even remember his name
now because i just think of him as spike
it would be um james mar james marsters
character from series two uh
okay is vera drinking yes meg
yes i was drinking to cleanse the taste
of skunk
spray out of my mouth
oh god that was
just one more
ah
okay what's your favorite asimov book
that's another author that i know a fair
bit about but have not uh finished any
of his works
would you ever watch return to oz again
yeah sure if somebody commissions me
uh all right what was i going to do this
oh i remember what it was going to be
next
okay so what i'm going to bring up now
we're going to do
uh whoa another
uh classic of
uh from the archives so this will be
the second video
uh in what was the uh
original incarnation of
uh of council of geeks
uh this will give you a better idea of
what a quote-unquote
standard uh
episode looked like than that first one
did
so i'll get that up i'll let it play
and uh and then i'll go back through and
talk about it uh so
okay yeah here we go
[Music]
new tournament fighter yeah
impressive breast physics
[Music]
yeah they've got a nice jiggle on some
of the curvier fighters too
[Music]
how's the game play i don't know
i turn it on and the opening cinematic
starts i get hypnotized and then it just
goes into demo mode and i
can't stop
doesn't the watching and fighters this
female heavy always suck
usually guess that's the price of
titillation
how you figure well it's like porn
you don't expect oscar caliber acting
just great titillation
you trade acting for boobs you're doing
the same here with the gameplay
i don't know if i'd go so far as to
compare it to porn
okay maybe that move possibly her
victory pose
hey guys what the hell is
you remember oh my god hey
why are her breasts bouncing
independently
of each other when she's not even moving
i don't know but it's strangely
beautiful
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
i still like i still like that
it's absolutely preposterous
and ridiculous and a little bit in
questionable taste
but i i still
i'm still
ridiculously excessively pleased with
myself for those
jokes oh
boy
so yeah that is the kind of thing uh
that council of geeks was
originally it's these three friends
having these like little one-off
conversations about
whatever the given topic was uh other
ones included
uh you know who's the best batman
debates over star wars versus star trek
um talking about video game movies and
uh and all kinds of stuff um
you know what i might show you one more
after this just
just to show you one specific thing
just because i'm pretty sure most of you
have never seen
uh that thing but let's let's go back
through this one
and i'll talk it through
so before we get too far in
uh you'll notice the theme music is the
same
opening credit music that i still use so
it was originally composed for this
version of council of geeks and i've
never stopped using it
oh and so this is what i mentioned
before about so these bits of art these
uh artistic renderings of the characters
and these are the character names
um these were done by
uh the brother of nathan who plays dave
so that he has sort of a the idea was
his
character was like the movie geek um so
that's why he's got like a film roll on
his chest
and then we had nicole who played kathy
and she was the fantasy geek and the big
reader so she her render has you know
the dragon and she's got the book she's
the elf ears um i think i think hers
came out the best
out of the three i i was kind of jealous
of how good hers was
and then my character matt
he's the gamer geek and so uh we
went with a cyborg rendering uh on him
[Music]
okay so the music in this
bit this was also composed by andrew
frappier who composed my main theme
of the one i still use and
the i i asked him for something that
would sound like
basically like tournament fighter
background music
the um the fighting noises
were done by nicole who plays kathy
and laura who's um my kid's mother
um we were still living together at the
time
so the voices of the yeah
oh all that um
that is that is both although actually
bad
correction this the dialogue lines
are both of them
but uh the grunts and the sounds
and the that's just laura
that was uh that was interesting to
record uh those sounds
new tournament fighter yeah
i am oddly proud of that cut
that i got the continuity of like he's
almost sat down in the one cut because
the other one and he finishes the
landing like i'm
i'm stupidly proud of that cut
and also like here's super young me
like i think so few people have probably
seen
this kind of hair on me because you know
before i started
growing it out and going without the hat
when i had the hat on
for a good chunk of that i had this hair
but i had the hat more often than i
didn't
so um i don't even know how many of you
folks are used to seeing me with hair
that short and glasses frames that
boring i didn't even have my ears
pierced yet my goodness
compressive breast physics
impressive breast physics is probably my
favorite
line of dialogue i've ever written in my
life
and i don't think that will ever change
i think that forevermore
no matter what i do even if i like get
booked to do uh something
you know big if if i get hired to write
um for doctor who someday
and the and i'm super proud of that work
i would still probably always be
proudest
of the line impressive breast physics
oh it's so stupid but like these
these are the kind of conversations that
i would actually
have it's
i i wish these shorts were not as
autobiographical as they
are but there you go yeah they've got a
nice
jiggle on some of the curvier fighters
too
how's the game play i don't know
i should be embarrassed opening
cinematic starts i get hypnotized and
then it just goes into demo mode and i
can't stop watching
uh doesn't the game play in fighters
this female heavy always
i do think in some ways like it goes
downhill after the impressive breast
physics line cause like then i'm kind of
almost trying to explain the joke
and like and it's strong it's like
barely over a minute i still
wonder if this overseas is welcome suck
usually guess that's the price of
titillation
how you figure well it's like porn
you don't expect oscar caliber acting
just great titillation
you trade acting for boobs you're doing
this
same here with the gameplay i don't know
if i'd go so far as to compare it to
porn
okay maybe that move okay i kind of like
that one too
um so like i i cannot remember all the
things that i
had uh the ladies say
um i i caught one of those like kick of
pixies
um but there was like fury of my fist
or something uh
but i i picked out kick of pixies that
was laura
kick off pixies
uh how many drinks have i had i've not
kept track
i'm finding this very amusing
possibly her victory pose
hey guys
okay so kathy who nicole is playing
is canonically lesbian that is something
that gets confirmed
i think the next episode
um that gets confirmed so um
my uh you know 30 year old
brain was like it's okay if all three of
them
are objectifying the the female computer
characters
a if a woman is present and b she's also
turned on
it's somehow in my brain that made sense
uh to be that young stupid again
wow hey not that young
why are her breasts bouncing
independently
of each other when she's not even moving
i don't know but it's strangely
beautiful
yeah okay that took an embarrassing
number of takes for us to get that yeah
together
[Laughter]
so many so many takes where that wasn't
[Music]
synced
oh good times
so let me clear that off and
re-embiggen myself
all right stick myself
there all right
uh so yeah that's uh that's something
more akin to what
um what a typical
episode of the original format of this
channel was like
i guess you say you guys are bosom buzz
buddies
oh god equal objectification i'm
there for it oh good that's that's a
relief to hear
i'm not embarrassed by this and paint us
all surprised oh
thanks meg ah
so yeah that was the kind of stuff that
was the birth of this
channel
oh it's uh
it's very odd to go back
uh
[Music]
so strange now are you still in contact
with them
um not really uh nicole
uh moved um
she moved to the caribbean i forget
where exactly
um so i haven't seen her in ages i
i used to occasionally see nathan at the
farmer's market because he
is a um
uh he's a blacksmith so he
sells his wares at uh at the farmers
market in town
of course that hasn't really been up and
running
uh due to covet concerns um i don't know
if they ever got it back up
and going again um some farmers markets
have i know the one in montpelier has
because i've been to it i don't know if
they ever restarted the one where i live
um but i see him every now and then and
i catch up with him
um but we're we're not uh we're not in
as close contact as we used to be part
of
that is like he's never on social media
and he doesn't answer texts
so like unless i bump into him i never
see the guy i never see her hear from
the guy
uh i i'm finding it interesting what
people are comparing it to i'm seeing
spaced i'm seeing red dwarf
see your doctor's first line's following
regeneration
impressive breast physics
i mean yeah
uh super chat isn't working oh
um well you can hit up the paypal which
actually i need to
check
so give me a minute on that
all right and also let me check
something else i've gotten
uh i'm getting texts from liz i'm gonna
tell her i'm
almost done
uh so checking the paypal
come on wake up you stupid thing
uh
not going to comment on that probably
wise uh oh
we got more woo let's see um
excuse me how do you feel about
reviewing fan-made projects if you were
commissioned of course
i am open to it um if it starts becoming
something that happens
regularly i might um put some kind of
caps or restrictions on it i've actually
got
um something along those lines in the
backlog
but as i'm behind so it's going to be a
little while before i get to it
um but i am not closed off to that
um the main thing that you need to be
aware of if you're going to commission
me to review
fan works especially if it's your own
fan work i'm going to judge it the same
way i judge anything else
so know that going in
and think really hard about whether or
not you want me to do that
because i would feel really bad
about taking your money and then saying
bad things about your work
but i'm gonna give my honest opinion
so yeah
just just be aware uh of that
possibility uh so okay
hold on i didn't i did put that in and
let's see
i got another one
thank you very much no questions came
with that one
all right
you should hum more often in your videos
[Music]
patreon perk sounds a little risque well
you know just depends on how perky it
gets
what am i on about okay um it is
it is about time for me to wrap it up
um we didn't hit the goal but like as i
said at the start of this thing i did
not expect to
we ra we raised nearly 700 which is
going to help
a lot um
and make my life a bit oh meg
uh which slash fake would you prefer
spiker giles
spike and giles are angel and wesley you
gotta do spike and giles if only so that
you can
have the callbacks to uh the randy giles
thing like you gotta you gotta do that
one
and of course of course meg you did 6.66
you devilish woman
uh okay
so i've got
one more video that i'm gonna show you
and i'm gonna show you this
for a very specific reason
which will probably become uh fairly
evident
uh relatively quickly into it
so let's see here let me find it
ah here we go it's going to be that one
get that going and
so this one
this is actually from god get nice and
uh hold on
this is gonna be a weird thing to say
this is from season
two of the original incarnation of
council of geeks
um i had two quote-unquote seasons
um worth of stuff uh
before and and then like one special
um afterwards
uh and one special in between them uh
before
sort of packing in the scripted shorts
so this is gonna be a new
uh opening credit sequence same music um
but uh new footage in it
so uh yeah
let me just get this going
oh boy uh people will realize quickly
why we're doing this one it's uh
[Music]
and she's back good to see you
hey i like what you've done oh thank you
oh i wouldn't go in there if i were you
why not he got clearance to start
working from home after you left
oh god why didn't you do something are
you nuts
i'm not going to touch him hey you good
luck
[Music]
hey so how was middle earth
epic how are you i can't complain
when was the last time you packaged the
start of the top had a haircut
i have determined that they are
pointless really
why should i spend 30 bucks every few
weeks you know for that same money
i could get six buy-ins at the magic
gathering tournament down at dark tower
gaming or even
better i could get three to six
hand games delivered from amazon don't
you have to leave
the house yeah i can see that you know
you don't give dave any crap about his
hair i would
steal dave's hair if i had half the
chance yours gets molester when you let
it grow out
are you applying that same retail logic
to deodorant
too i have not gotten to the store in a
little while and now you may never get
there
i see you've congealed into the sofa you
know there are places on this planet
where they would bottle my musk and
sell you why don't you go there
do you want in on this i think it might
be better to play
from a distance online no it would be
if your little jaunter on the islands
had wiped you out financially and left
you incapable of buying your own copy
new challenger you're getting chain mail
i'm out of shirts
wins
oh
yeah oh
god
oh dear oh dear oh dear dear so
um yeah obviously there are some uh
some quarantine parallels to be had
there
but more specifically it's the fact that
i grew a
beard and here's the thing
that you need to realize nathan also had
a beard
but he just grew it cause he looked good
in a beard
me i grew it for
that joke
and it i hate it looked
awful and it felt worse it was this
scraggly
wiry patchy ah it was
terrible it looked bad it
felt bad my my daughter was too young to
remember what i looked like with that
but i've shown her pictures
since and after i did that every day for
a month she said
just a reminder you look terrible with a
beard lest i ever forget
but i grew it out
for i think that was
that was almost a month of growth that
pathetic
okay let's go back through this
uh so yeah the new um i think that was
my favorite part of the new opening
credits was
having uh each of the the characters
kind of
have a have an item there so
um dave nathan got the lightsaber
and this was also meant to correspond
with the characters associated fandoms
because
in sorting out uh their geekeries i
decided that dave was a star wars fan
kathy was a um star trek fan and matt
was a whovian
so i i had fun with that um
some of these are clips that you've seen
before already and
we've got the uh assuming the poses
again that one's smoother now
i think that's even the same footage um
and this
was the channel logo for a while
um even after i stopped doing the
scripted shorts
uh i i really did want to bring nathan
because nathan
like uh nicole was a bit of a geek too
but nathan was definitely uh the kind of
geek who would totally ramble in front
of a camera
we just never got anything worked out
for him to just come and chat
i kind of wish we had um but that was
the logo for the team
so she opens coming in saying and she's
back
so i came up with like story beats that
nobody freaking care but like
the idea was the reason there had been a
gap in between
seasons uh was that she
had taken a trip to new zealand um which
was actually why
she uh didn't appear in the previous
episode to this
um because she wasn't back yet and so
now she's back
and she's back and good to see you
i had to add a little line in here where
she compliments his beard
uh because when i originally wrote the
script i didn't know he was going to
grow a beard
there's my my sign david tennant um not
signed directly for me that was
something i got i think i was
i was given that as a gift but i i've
not met david tennant
hey i like what you've done i don't
think okay i wouldn't
it's kind of weird seeing the wall of
movies because i
a fair amount of that stuff i got rid of
i like i did a i've still got a lot of
movies on dvd
but i did do a bit of a um
what is murray condo does does this
bring joy
purge a couple of times although the
question i asked is am i
realistically ever going to actually sit
down and watch this again
um or would it break my heart if i was
uh
if it was not available on streaming and
i couldn't see it anymore and if the
answer was
no then you know i got rid of it go in
there if i were you so
i don't have the same movie collection
you got parents to start working from
home after you left
oh god why didn't you do something are
you nuts
i'm not going to touch him hey you good
luck
[Music]
oh god look at that thing
it's pitiful it doesn't even connect to
the sideburns
that's how pathetic my attempt at
growing a beard was
oh that's all that's how is middle earth
epic how are you i can't complain
what was the last time you packaged the
start of the top had a haircut
i have to okay so that that uh
chain mail that was
cold that was really cold
to put on and we shot this like in
summer
but that's that was freezing to put that
on my
on my skin and like i put it on and like
eventually kind of warmed up a little
bit but every now and then i'd shift
and like a couple of the the chains and
the chain mail
that that hadn't been in contact in my
skin and hadn't absorbed my body he
would come into contact and i'd get this
little
like on my back or something um
all for a joke that i'm not even sure is
that funny
determined that they are pointless
really
why should i spend 30 bucks every few
weeks you know for that same money
i could get six buy-ins at the magic
gathering tournament down at dark tower
games
better i could get three to six
second-hand games delivered
from amazon is this person
yeah i can see that you know you don't
give
dave any crap about his hair i would
steal dave's hair if i had half the
chance
yours gets it grow molester-y
and there's even like a mug that like i
shouldn't grow my hair out like what
what the hell god
are you applying that same detail logic
to deodorant
too i have not gotten to the store in a
little while and
oh my god okay look look at that
look at look at it
look at this thing on my
face like that
that thing over there ah
dear lord it's not
i would say it looks villainy but it's
too it's too scriley it's too much of a
mess
now you may never get there i see you i
don't regret growing it out for this gag
i'm not sure it was worth it but musk
why
[Music]
and so you're also getting more um
more sound effects uh from the
tournament fighter
the make-believe tournament fighter uh
and a little bit more of that music i i
i would say it's a continuity not except
i was uh
i didn't want to ask the uh my composer
to
to make more music for me because at
that point in time
i could not pay people um
like i didn't pr it wasn't done for
exposure he actually he was um
he was a he was a friend of my
daughter's mother so he you know he did
it as a favor
um so there wasn't really the promise of
exposure but like since
he had done it for free i was not gonna
ask uh for any more pieces of music
than he'd already made um and obviously
at this point i
pay people if they're gonna provide me
anything
i think it might be better to play from
a distance
online no it would be
if your little jaunter on the islands
had to wipe you out financially and left
you incapable of buying your own copy
new challenger
[Music]
i had legitimately forgotten about
bristino
wins
that's so that's so wrong
oh lord okay
i think uh i think we're gonna call it a
wrap
on this oh my goodness
this um this has been quite the evening
you do realize photos of bearded you are
gonna hunt you forever now i mean they
might as well
it it'll ensure that you know
other people won't make my mistake
i hope um you could still rock the
chainmail though i've still got that
chainmail shirt somewhere i think it's
in my closet
somewhere uh
you made it ah crap i
did promise that son of a
oh dang it
fine so here's how this is gonna have to
work
i can't do this the way i've been doing
the other things where it's gonna play
on my own stream
because it's copyrighted
and it'll get the stream taken down and
i'll lose the monetization and the
monetization
was the entire point on this one so
what i'm gonna have to do oh and for
people who don't know
there are people in my chat who have
been hollering
at me for ages
to uh to watch a little something called
the doctor in distress which
i've never seen i think it was done like
to try and
garner support for um
trying to get trying to get doctor who
back off the air this was during the
hiatus
um so
i've had people
pressuring me to watch this forever
i have been putting it off
and now i
am for this occasion
going to watch doctor who
doctor in distress
which is available on youtube i am going
to watch
the music video version which is
three minutes 47 seconds
i am not listening to the extended
version
you cannot make me i will not
do it
so okay
how this is going to work i'm going to
watch this on my phone
if you want to sync up and see it on
your end as well so you understand what
i'm reacting to
you have to do it on your end because as
i said i can't show this here
because i'll get shut down for copyright
but here we go
the doctor in distress
okay
that's um
[Music]
that's an aggressive beat
where did they find people
to volunteer for this
oh god
um
whoa okay that's intense um
uh oh no
oh colin no
oh lord
i'm not even sure who that is but she's
off key so i'm assuming she's from the
show
are they all actors from the show or the
are
just some of them is the doctor who
production team oh god
yeah you can tell you you can tell
they're not
singers
oh
how far into the semi there's still over
a minute to go i
like thank god i didn't try and do the
whoa okay whoever that was thinks they
can sing
oh my god
oh god
oh dear god no
no you are all better than this
the chorus is like a
it's like a children's choir but like
not like a
good one it's like going to see your
kids choral recital in grade school
oh dear god
oh we would like to thank everyone in
involved for kindly giving their time
for a good cause
no that was not a good that was a
travesty
what the oh god that
freaking song
is now going to be in my head
for the rest of the goddamn weak
at minimal
you sons of
why did you do this to me why did you
want me to why
why did you do that what did i do to you
[Applause]
lord that's gonna be stuck in my
freaking head
that is not fair
ah
look i wasn't expecting good
but it's just the fact that
it's so repetitive
and that like there's that one singer
who's so enthusiastic
you can tell she thinks she's good and i
don't feel
nice about knocking anyone's singing
ability but it's like that was a whole
lot of gumption behind
not a lot of skill oh
okay i'm checking the paypal
nothing new has come in okay
we're calling it a day holy
cow
oh
rowan
ben whoever your cohort
cohorts were
ah
okay that's it
i'm done i'm spent
i just i i'm gonna go lay down
and try and
not succumb to madness
dear lord thank you all for joining me
thank you to everybody who contributed
this is going to be an immense help it's
going to make
my life a lot easier
uh hans zimmer did the music
well so that's what he's been trying to
pay penance for all these decades
okay all right everybody thank you very
much
for joining me thank you for watching
um this sort of format might become
more standard because i know i look
better coming in through the
uh the webcam uh and while i do like
having the background i
the the delay uh between
when i say something when you guys see
it and then you know me being able to
react to what you type that
i don't love that um but i'm not sure if
i if i have a way around that but
in any case thank you very much
thank you for being here for supporting
me
for putting up with me
indulging me today
um
just thank you
this the fact that this is my job is
still
kind of incredible
thank you take care of yourselves out
there be
safe you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meeting and until next time
this council is adjourned